socrier
poyet qui dieu stadistes seront
notamment à preignac j'espère qu'il
donnera
sa feuille à syrte avola a mis
dans une autre vie oleg était pasteur
aujourd'hui non cadres cette unité de
jeunes volontaires
ces garçons vont s'envoler dans la
défense territoriale pour défendre kiev
la plupart n'ont aucune expérience donc
notre objectif c'est de les entraîner
c'est ce qu'on fait depuis deux semaines
on les prépare à partir au front
les membres de la défense territoriale
ont leur propre hiérarchie
mais ils sont intégrés aux forces armées
ukrainiennes
parmi ces nouvelles recrues beaucoup
tiennent un fusil d'assaut pour la
première fois
aux commandes ce jour-là un ancien
sous-officier de l'armée régulière
comme tous les cadres de cette unité il
est membre de l'organisation des
nationalistes ukrainiens aux
zones est une force créée par nos
ancêtres pour défendre l'ukraine
c'est un symbole de la lutte pour la
liberté de notre pays et pour la
sauvegarde tout ce que les russes
tentent de détruire depuis 400 ans
battus dans le dôme basse dès 2014
l'organisation existe depuis près d'un
siècle et continue à séduire malgré son
passé sulfureux elle a activement
collaboré avec les nazis avant et
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale au
nom de la lutte commune contre les
soviétiques
regiment of travis hector ces mouvements
ultra nationalistes sont au coeur de la
propagande russe qui clame que l'ukraine
est aux mains des nazis
oleg lui affirme que les positions
extrémistes sont minoritaires dans leurs
rangs
some people certains membres vont trop
loin
mais ils ne sont pas représentatifs de
ces organisations
poutine nous traite de nazis
moi je lui réponds que ce n'est pas nous
qui tuons des civils
nous aimons notre pays est ce que ça
fait de nous des nazis je ne crois pas
depuis l'invasion russe own dit avoir
déployé plus de 500 combattants dont une
grande partie autour de kiev ces hommes
nous emmène sur une de leurs positions
avancées à l'ouest de la capitale
ukrainienne
ici c'est l'une des zones les plus
importantes
les russes tendre d'attaqué kiev par le
nord et par l'ouest
il y a deux jours à peine il était à 800
mètres d'ici mais nous avons réussi à
les repousser
deux nouvelles recrues donnent seront
bientôt envoyés au front pour combattre
aux côtés de l'armée ukrainienne